à moins d'un mois du premier tour des
élections présidentielles les différents
partis accélèrent leur campagne samedi
12 mars les militants du mouvement
l'union populaire de jean luc mélenchon
se sont mobilisés sur le terrain au
programme à plaisir tractage et porte à
porte willy à des échanges sur ce qui
les révoltes en ce moment et comment
nous collectivement on peut améliorer
leur quotidien pour ça que c'est pas
vraiment un département qui a très ancré
à gauche c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire mais mais ça se passe plutôt bien
pour l'instant c'est à dire que on est
bien accueilli surtout dans les
quartiers populaires là où on va faire
la plupart de nos actions militantes
l'occasion de répondre aux
préoccupations des français sur des
sujets d'actualité avec des points
phares du programme augmenter le smig
tout le monde est pour la retraite à 60
ans tout le monde et pour rétablir lisf
tout le monde et pour arrêter le
glyphosate tout le monde et pau enfin
ainsi de suite quoi comprend les grands
tous les grands éléments du programme la
location de 1000 centres euros pour les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qui moi m'intéresse
pas mal le sujet de l'écologie aussi
parce que c'est un sujet qui est
complètement oubliée dans la campagne
jusqu'ici du côté du parti reconquête
d'eric zemmour les militants sont aussi
au rendez vous dimanche 13 mars c'était
l'opération les 48 heures de la
reconquête partout en france et même
dans le petit village yvelinois
darsonville les bus des 48 heures de la
reconquête c'était d'aller au contact
des concitoyens notamment dans ce
village où il ya un fort taux
d'abstention de connaître quels étaient
leurs préoccupations pourquoi il n'avait
pas été aussi voter on a remarqué que
beaucoup étaient désespérés par la
politique ils ne savaient pas trop pour
qui voter un temps des changes
directement au contact des citoyens pour
revenir sur les mesures du programme de
leur candidat la préservation de la
culture française qui voulu par eric
zemmour notamment avec la préservation
de la culture française et des
traditions françaises judéo-chrétienne
la protection des os mobiles des
automobilistes pardon avec la
suppression du permis à points d'accord
la protection de la ruralité avec la
prime des 10000 euros qui sera donnée
aux parents qui souhaitent avoir un
enfant au sein de la rivalité est aussi
la préservation des petits points
commerce de proximité qui sont vraiment
le coeur de nos villages la campagne
s'intensifie pour les militants ils
resteront mobilisés jusqu'au dernier
jour de la campagne 8 avril avant le
premier tour prévu deux jours après